[Music]
the rise of these variants
getting vaccinated
hey guys good morning so i just went on
my morning walk and i had some coffee
now i'm gonna work out and then i gotta
get the van ready to go
i've been camped at the same spot for
about 10 days now so
um i have some stuff by the fire pit and
i'm gonna collect all my trash in the
bear bin
do my dishes have some errands to run in
the city and
i don't know where i'm gonna camp after
that but i'll figure it out
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was getting kind of cloudy out now we
got some rain
out here i used my bear canister that i
actually use for through hikes
to keep other trash you know like when
i'm camped out for a couple of days
just so that rodents can't get in there
and and so it doesn't stink up the
interior of the van
and then these are my recyclables so i'm
gonna take these into town today
and dump those just took a walk around
camp
made sure nothing else was around
i think we are good to go
normally i just dump out my small bags
of trash at the gas station whenever i'm
fueling up but when i'm out camping in
places for long amounts of time
i have like two to three small bags so i
usually just find a city park or
something
they have big dumpsters or even just
regular trash cans and that's usually
where i drop it off
the weather's so interesting today it's
like stormy and rainy and moody and then
sunny and beautiful it's all over the
place i love it but anyway i'm all
packed up
got everything ready to go and now i
need to run into town
to do some errands so i need to shower
and do laundry
um get some groceries fill my water
tanks and pick up mail let's get out of
[Music]
here
washboard roads are not my favorite
maybe i'm just going to go faster
and i've seen those wolves gather
i just dropped off my trash and now i'm
heading to
a postal depot i believe it's called
um i had a package shipped from my
mailbox in washington
down here to arizona and yeah it's
basically
got my mail from the last two months i
think
so i think there are some toll bills in
there
so definitely need to get those and some
checks
[Music]
got a bunch of financial stuff and my
tool
also this mystery box from
australia
what is this so cool
they match their hands for sure
[Music]
all right so i just took a shower and it
feels great now i
am going to go do laundry
do some work while i'm getting laundry
done and then
grocery shopping and i gotta grab one
more mail package
[Music]
all right so i'm at the laundry place
and waiting for my stuff to dry
it's kind of loud here hopefully you
guys can hear me all right but
it's too hot to have the window shut i'm
dying so i wanted to talk to you guys
about mail
when i first moved into my suv i was
thinking like how am i going to get mail
how am i going to register my business
and pay taxes and do all that legal
stuff and some of it i'm still figuring
out
which by the way if any of you know a
great cpa in washington state
please comment below i'm definitely
shopping for one so there are a couple
different options when it comes to mail
first you could ask friends or family
and that's what i did for the first year
i changed my address to my mom's address
in florida and
i just had everything forwarded there
[Music]
the laundry's done anyway um i just had
everything forwarded there
and when something important was coming
i already knew because i signed up for
usps digital scans so that every day i
would get an email and it would show me
a photo of what was arriving
so i basically told my mom just throw
out everything
unless i send you a text and say hey can
you hold on to this for me
and she was great she'd either hold on
to it or you know just like take a photo
of it with her phone and then i'd have a
copy
so for 10.99 tax forms i would just get
a digital copy of that that was super
easy
um and then if it was a check from a
client then i just gave her my sign-in
information for my mobile banking app
and she could just take care of that for
me but after a year i decided it'd be so
much easier to just have my own private
mailbox in washington being able to have
products shipped there made way more
sense than having it shipped to florida
and then forwarded on
so that's what i did i got a private
mailbox it's about thirty dollars every
three months
and they're great so how it works is
let's say right now
i'm in arizona i can call them up and
say hey did
any packages arrive for me um would you
mind opening this box and seeing what's
in it
and then they collect all the things
that i'd like to have forwarded to
wherever i happen to be and that's
actually what i just had done and that's
the package that i picked up the big
white box
um so yeah that works out really well
and you just pay the shipping cost to
have it
sent and then sometimes you have to pay
a fee to pick it up at whatever location
they send it to
so today it was like four dollars plus
the 32 dollars
for shipping another option for
receiving packages on the road is using
amazon prime
and this is not an ad for them i love
this option because
they have many many different pickup
locations they have amazon lockers where
they email you a code and you just go
pick up your item
you can get them at gnc counters you can
get them
at kohl's i believe 7-elevens there's
quite a few different options and
returns are super easy they just email
you a return
code and you go to the ups store i also
i think kohl's you can as well
and you just have them scan your phone
and it doesn't even have to be
repackaged they take care of all of that
and the other great thing is amazon
prime offers
two free day shipping on a lot of items
which is huge when you live on the road
because
i don't know where i'm gonna be a week
from now much less like five days
two days i can generally tell so having
something shipped to the city i'm in to
a locker is like perfect
another option when it comes to shopping
is just ordering online and then having
that item
shipped directly to the store for pickup
so i've done this
often with best buy and target if i need
to replace a camera sd card and i know
i'm going to be passing through a major
city in the next couple days while
driving
then i'll just order it online and have
it shipped there and pick it up when i'm
passing through
there are a few other options that i've
used on the road um ups
fedex and the united states postal
service so if ups
is pretty straightforward they generally
charge a five dollar fee
um fedex i believe is free fedex to
fedex with the usps i've had kind of a
mixed bag of experiences
one time it was free and completely easy
and straightforward another time i was
charged one dollar per package
and another time the manager just
refused to give me my package because i
hadn't called ahead of time to confirm
um so i don't really know what to tell
you with that i think it's just kind of
like a mystery
but the best way to avoid any kind of
issues
is to just call ahead of time and
confirm that wherever you're wanting to
ship your item
that they can in fact receive on your
behalf and
ask them how much it is give them your
name and your estimated shipping date
and
that way they're expecting you and you
hopefully won't run into any issues oh
and one last note with the usps
it's called general delivery and this is
the format that they usually have you
use
when sending a package but like i said
just call and make sure ahead of time
all right so i hope that was helpful i
will include a link to the usps digital
scan
service below it's actually just the
united states postal service website but
i thought that was really cool and super
helpful it doesn't actually work for
every address like it doesn't work now
for my private mailbox but
i think that if you just put in your
address it will tell you right away
whether or not you're eligible
oh and one last note uh this probably
goes without saying but the biggest tip
i can offer
is to take everything online so your
bills
your banking your subscriptions um most
of my client payments are done
via direct deposit and most of my tax
forms are done
via digital download or email so the
more you can move online
the easier and the less stuff you have
to carry around with you in paper format
also
every single bill that i have is
scheduled for auto pay so i don't ever
have to think about it
and then just a receipt is emailed to me
every month and i can look it up if i
need to
but that has simplified my life
immensely what else
i think that's it anyway i'm gonna go
grab my laundry
and then finish a few more errands
[Music]
and i've tasted too many temptations
got a toilet replacement because i've
had mine for almost two years now
and some other stuff
[Music]
final stop i'm getting gas and then
heading
out to the desert
[Applause]
[Music]
you